Good morning. We are going to be in Psalm 2, so it should be right next to where we were last week.
If you still marked there Psalm 1, you can turn there in your Bible if you have one, or it's also in the Worship Guide.
We're going to start with reading this and then we'll pray and get into it.
Why do the nations rage and the peoples plot in vain?
The kings of the earth set themselves and the rulers take counsel together against the Lord and against his anointed,
saying, let us burst their bonds apart and cast away their cords from us.
He who sits in the heavens laughs. The Lord holds them in derision.
Then he will speak to them in his wrath and terrify them in his fury,
saying, as for me, I have set my king on Zion, my holy hill.
I will tell of the decree. The Lord said to me, you are my son. Today I have begotten you.
Ask of me and I will make the nations your heritage and the ends of the earth your possession.
You shall break them with a rod of iron and dash them in pieces like a potter's vessel.
Now therefore, O kings, be wise, be warned, O rulers of the earth, serve the Lord with fear and rejoice with trembling.
Kiss the son lest he be angry and you perish in the way, for his wrath is quickly kindled.
Blessed are all who take refuge in him.
Let's pray. Father, holy is your name.
We come before you today from many places, from many families, together as one.
As those called by your grace to be astoundingly called your children
and to be able to call you Father, Lord, is a privilege that we too often take for granted.
So we thank you for that, Lord.
As we explore your word today, Lord, I pray that you would speak to us,
that I would not be the one speaking, that anything that I say that would get in the way would be pushed to the side
and quickly forgotten, Lord, but that your truth, your forever good word,
would press deep into our hearts and transform us.
And we offer all of this in the name of our King and our brother Jesus. Amen.
Alright. So, forgive me. My voice just came back, so if I'm shouting at some point,
it's because I'm compensating for just now being able to speak again.
In his Masterpiece, The Lord of the Rings, J.R.R. Tokian communicates a lot of great points.
There's many things that could be pulled from there.
I am not one that's going to seek to find the most profound, but we are going to start there.
You know that, well, if anybody's not familiar with the story, it's totally fine. It's forgivable.
But you have like two weeks to fix that.
But if you're not familiar, two of the main characters are two hobbits
who are little people, halflings they call them, which has got to be the most humbling thing to be in all fiction.
Frodo is the main character in his friend and gardener, Samwise Gamgee,
if I'm pronouncing that differently than you, I apologize.
As hobbits, they are without a doubt the least impressive members of the fellowship that is assembled early in the story,
which includes a wizard, multiple members of royal families, an elf, very impressive people, and then these halflings.
But the way that the story develops by design and then partly by the way things unfold,
the burden falls to Frodo with Samwise's companion to actually bear the ring, which is the mission of the fellowship.
They are formed to destroy this ring, to defeat their enemy, the one who would take the hearts and lives of men and all of Middle Earth.
So in their journey they encounter a lot of difficulties, a lot of turmoil,
things that they wouldn't expect as hobbits typically, who live fairly simple lives enjoying food and drink and music,
not unlike Americans in many ways and those of our modern world.
But in the midst of this journey, Sam is always reflecting. We get a lot of insight to his thoughts.
He's a very mindful little hobbit.
And at one point, as they're walking and they've been through many things to this point, Sam looks over at Mr. Frodo.
I believe it's in the two towers. He says, I wonder, Mr. Frodo, what sort of tale we have fallen into?
When I was getting ready to try to preach on Psalm 2, and we're looking forward to go through all of the Psalms
several this summer, and then Brandon said all of them ultimately is our goal.
It's a big body of work to go through. A lot of prayers, there's Psalms of lament, Psalms of praise.
You hear a lot of raw emotion, a lot of declaration of victory. Some that have already happened, some that are to come.
But in the midst of that, I think it's really helpful that we have Psalm 1, which Brandon spoke on last week,
and Psalm 2 this week, that I think helped tell us a little bit about the story that we've fallen into.
So I want you to kind of have that mindset. We're going to go through some questions on that
that I think will help us draw out some of what we're being told here.
So as we look and we think about the story we inhabit, there's four questions that I want us to kind of go through.
So we're going to hit these as quickly as we can. It's a lot of ground to cover.
And I forgot to start a timer, so we'll see what we can do.
The first question is exactly what Sam said, what sort of tale or story are we in?
Is it the same one maybe that the writer of this Psalm was talking about? How is it different? How might it correlate?
Second, who's writing this story? Does it matter? Is there an author? Who is he?
What might his intention be with this story?
Third, maybe if we understand these first two questions, how might we best participate in the story that we're in,
given the nature of it and the author?
And lastly, how does it end? Everybody knows a good story, a good movie, a good book, a TV show can be ruined with a terrible ending.
Am I right? I'm not going to name names, but we all know.
So the way that we're going to do this is we're going to go through the whole Psalm.
I know, it's a lot of verses.
With kind of a 30,000 foot view, we're going to hit what's being said and then we're going to drop down a little lower.
The reason for this is because I think with these types of passages, for me, big sweeping passages that cover a whole lot of ground,
it can be really easy to read it and be, wow, that's really wonderful.
And it's also kind of hard to get your arms around. It doesn't necessarily come all the way down to ground level on Monday morning, right?
So what we're going to try to do is go through quickly and then drop down for a closer look and see how this connects for each of us.
So first question, what kind of story do we find ourselves in?
So for this, I want to start, I want to look back at verses one through three.
So I'm going to read these again quickly.
Why do the nations rage and the peoples plot in vain?
The kings of the earth set themselves and the rulers take counsel together against the Lord and His anointed saying,
let us burst their bonds apart and cast away their cords from us.
First of all, this kind of feels like we're dropping into the middle of a story, right?
Like we're already talking about nations raging and the rulers taking counsel.
Like these characters are just no introduction, they're here.
But then there's a brief mention of the Lord.
So we kind of have some things going on.
So a couple of quick things that are mentioned here that are definitely integral to the story is first, the nations rage.
First line.
Thankfully, this is definitely something in the past and we don't have to deal with this anymore,
but we'll just, everybody use your imagination.
Just imagine people behaving in a tribal manner, setting themselves up against one another with ill intent,
perhaps even not fairly engaging one another.
In this time I would imagine it looks like David, many of the Psalms are attributed to him.
This one is even referenced at one point to him.
He lived a life of constant conflict.
He was under pursuit from people who were literally wanting his head.
They wanted his blood.
So when they're talking about nations raging, it's pretty open hostility.
In many ways that's not what we've experienced, but I'm sure if you log on to any social media,
you might see some measure of hostility against the other.
So maybe keep that in mind.
Nations raging.
Feels like that may still be here.
Next, the people's plot in vain.
So people's being people, maybe people groups plotting in vain.
So working, trying to fabricate measures or systems, but to no avail, right?
Like it's like in vain.
We keep trying, but we're not getting to where we want to be.
No matter what promises may be made, it all seems to fall apart.
Third, we see a reference to some characters here about this story.
The kings of the earth.
Now this I think is important because this is an easy line for me as a modern westerner to see this living in Gondale, Alabama.
Like kings of the earth is kind of a, just a phrase, kind of like out of a fairy tale or a story long ago.
We don't have kings, right?
We don't have kings.
But then maybe let's sit with that for just a second.
Kings of the earth would be rulers, people with authority, people with influence.
Only there were a term for someone who wielded influence, maybe an influencer, or maybe someone who has a large audience of followers.
Perhaps someone with a podcast or a book deal.
There's all sorts of people with platforms, right?
We're always talking about who we're platforming.
In fact, you could argue that many of our folks with a smartphone and a little bit of text savvy, which I do not have,
wield more influence than these kings with swords and armies did millennia ago, right?
Because they can reach more, the speed of information is astounding.
So maybe keeping that in mind.
I think there's three points, and this is my one attempt at alliteration.
So I would, you can just give me a little bit of grace here.
I may or may not have listened to Tim Kelly in prepping for this.
So the kings of the earth, we have false kings that rule fabricated kingdoms that are built upon and perpetuated by our disordered fears.
So I want to, we're going to come back to that, but false kings fabricated kingdoms or spheres of power that are built upon and perpetuated by our disordered fears.
Now that gives us a little bit of insight.
Again, we're dropping into the middle of this story.
It might be how you feel today.
It might be how you felt at many points in your life.
You're like, how in the world did this get like this?
You may even feel that way thinking back from 10 years ago, five years ago to present.
So we're just kind of orienting ourselves.
We don't want to be overwhelmed by it.
So the next question, which this is actually where things get a little bit more clear, I think.
So who's the author of this story?
It's referenced right here that the rulers are taking counsel against the Lord.
So let's talk about who the author is.
Now this Psalm and the book of Psalms was assembled carefully and we believe, you know, is the inspired word.
But these songs were written at different times.
There's some songs, like we said, many attributed to David in these prayers, these songs, these words that were recited and learned and memorized by the Hebrew people.
Again, going back, Psalm 1 and 2 are kind of set here as a level set, right, to help us understand.
So, recognizing they were doing that with an understanding.
There was an assumption that we know who they're talking about when they say the Lord.
And in our English Bible, my understanding is that when you see the Lord written in all caps, that is a reference to the name Yahweh,
which is the name that God has revealed to himself in Scripture as he who is.
I am who I am.
And so, let's just talk briefly about who we're talking about.
Again, this is not in the passage, but this would have been assumed for those reading it.
So, who is he?
Well, we can start with the very first page in your Bible.
In the beginning, God created the heavens and the earth.
So he is the creator.
There's a lot of speculation in modern debate on what that means, what it means to create, what it means to bring order.
We talk about in the beginning, you know, there was chaos over the waters and the Spirit of God hovered over the waters of chaos.
And there's a lot that you can dive into with that.
But I think the most important thing is that we recognize that there's one who holds authority.
He created the heavens and the earth, that which is above and that which we inhabit here.
Secondly, and this is a verse that gets quoted many, many times in Scripture by Scripture.
And this is Exodus 34-6 telling us who he is.
Yahweh, a God merciful and gracious, slow to anger and abounding in steadfast love and faithfulness,
keeping steadfast love for thousands, forgiving iniquity and transgression and sin.
But who will by no means clear the guilty, visiting the iniquity of the fathers on the children and the children's children to the third and fourth generation?
That's a big definition for this author.
So, who is the author?
What does this passage tell us?
We're going to look at verses 4-6 next.
So first in verse 4 the author, the Lord, he's unshaken.
We see he who sits in the heavens laughs.
The Lord holds them in derision.
So as these kings of the earth are setting themselves up and taking counsel amongst themselves, it would seem he's unbothered.
He is unshaken.
But then in verse 5 it says, then he will speak to them in his wrath and terrify them in his fury.
So we see he's not indifferent.
He's unshaken.
Yes, but he is not uninvolved.
He is not indifferent.
He is paying attention.
Third, verses 6-9, as for me, I have set my king on Zion, my holy hill.
And then I will tell of the decree, the Lord said to me, you are my son.
Today I have begotten you, ask of me.
I will make the nations your heritage, the ends of the earth your possession.
You shall break them with a rod of iron and bash them in pieces like a potter's vessel.
He has a plan.
He's not only unshaken, he's not indifferent.
In fact, he has a very specific plan and king in mind.
So with that plan, we kind of get a little bit of insight there too.
So there will be resolution.
The nations rage, conflicts, but there will be resolution that would appear.
That's actually a little terrifying the way that it goes.
But also we see there is a true king.
So in verse 7, you are my son.
We see this king is not simply a man, but he is associated with God.
He is like God.
This is where we see one of many countless references and you will certainly hear it here at Trinity.
References to God the son who is one in essence with the father while being a distinct person.
Verse 8, the ends of the earth, this king's rule is to be complete.
It's not going to be a little territory that he gets.
He doesn't just get to have his little island or his encampment where they throw walls up.
His rule is to be complete to the ends of the earth.
Third, in verse 9, the rod of iron which has got to be the most uncomfortable part of this.
Like we grew up in many of us, at least myself.
I know there are those present who did not, but I grew up in the Bible Belt South.
And I grew up in the 90s where we were kind of moving into Jesus loves you.
And that was kind of the mantra which is totally true and we embrace that.
But the idea of one, a Jesus who would carry a rod of iron, a little unsettling, right?
But this would indicate in their language and in ours, I think we could say that his rule is strong and just.
It is not one that yields, it's not soft, it's not flimsy, it's firm.
Now, recognizing the nature of the story we're in and the character of the author and what his plan might be,
how can we best participate? Work, play, laugh, cry, love, fall, get back up in this story.
I'm glad you asked. I'm glad you're on that question too.
In verse 10 it says, now therefore, be wise, O Kings, be warned, O rulers of the earth.
Now, again this is one that I would kind of gloss over. I'm not a ruler of the earth.
I go to my job, I try to maintain my household imperfectly as my wife can attest.
I'm not a ruler. I don't know that this really applies to me.
It sounds like for really important people, right?
So they need to be wise and sure, make sure that they are warned about their authority.
But I would implore you and myself to maybe recognize, especially where we find ourselves,
we do carry and bear responsibility and authority to a point.
Many of us have wealth unimaginable to the people that this was originally written to and among.
Wealth unimaginable and authority unimaginable to people across the globe.
The idea of being able to get in your own automobile and dictate your schedule for the day
is something that most of humans across history would not even have a concept for.
So maybe recognize that we do have authority and with that,
I ought to quote Spider-Man with that responsibility, with great power comes great responsibility.
So be wise and be warned.
Verse 11, serve the Lord with fear.
Serve the Lord with fear.
So we see in Proverbs, many of us have maybe heard it quoted,
that the fear of the Lord is the beginning of wisdom.
There's something earlier we mentioned about disordered fears.
It is not that there is no fear in life, right?
There are things that it's good to be afraid of.
It's good to teach your child to be afraid of the hot stove.
It's difficult sometimes to teach some children that maybe don't climb up that high.
You need to be afraid of that height because you could fall.
But properly ordered fears are good.
So maybe serving with fear is the proper posture that we come with.
But then immediately after that, rejoice with trembling.
This would be a rejoicing that's characterized by joy, exhilaration.
Think about the things that make you tremble.
I tremble a little bit getting up here. I was anxious, a little nervous, but excited.
Also a sense of awe would accompany this rejoicing.
I'm going to do this too. I quoted Tolkien and I can't do that without a reference to Lewis.
One of my favorite pictures of this rejoicing with trembling is when anyone in the Chronicles of Narnia stories encounters the king.
Who is, again for those of you who may have forgotten your children's stories, a gigantic lion as long as you can.
And there's a lion when one of the little girls, I think it's Lucy, hears that he's a lion.
People have been talking about this king and she said, oh, he's a lion? Is he safe?
And they look at her and they laugh and they say, of course he's not.
Who said anything about safe? But he's good. He's the king.
And then when they encounter him, it is almost a sense of trembling and also you're drawn to him, right?
And so in that sense of trembling there is rejoicing because all of these things that we may be tempted to give our joy to,
to give our attention to, they all come up short. They all seem to be done in vain.
But there's one that isn't. There's one that actually far exceeds our expectations.
And that one leaves us trembling, satisfied, and yet we know that there will never be too much desire in us for him.
And so this is, this is what we're told is how we move forward.
And then verse 12. So I said the rod of iron was probably the toughest one, but this might actually be the toughest one in terms of just disarming us, right?
Kiss the sun. Kiss the sun. Embrace. I think this would be an intimate embrace to the king, which is exploding a lot of categories here, right?
There's no decorum. We're kissing the sun. And this is actually where we see that I was asking the wrong question.
How is not the question. We don't need a how so much as we need a who.
So this is, this is the point of the passage. We've reached it. It's not a how.
We do have all of these things happening and we're going to talk about those.
But what we need is not a system, not, not a revamped 2.0 system to follow.
Because no matter what system we put into place, we have broken sinful hearts.
We're going to drop it. It could be the greatest system.
But if you put it in the hands of one who doesn't know, doesn't have the capability to bear it, it will still leave us lacking.
Brandon talked last week about blessed is the man who meditates on the law of the Lord in Psalm 1.
The law is good. The law tells us how to live. But we in and of ourselves find ourselves falling short and not just falling short a little bit, right?
Go through the 10 commandments. We've broken all of them. Jesus says if you even have a desire in your mind to anger towards your brother,
you've already committed murder. Like, he doesn't want us to just be able to follow a prescription. He wants us to be transformed to come alive.
So we don't need a how. We need a who.
So this is where we're going to drop down a little bit. Because I want us to not just go out with a good feeling about how great everything is going to be and how crazy it is now.
I want us to leave here recognizing that this and all of Scripture comes down all the way to the ground level. All the way down.
It's very concrete. Despite maybe our temptation. So I mean, we've discussed cosmic conflict, the creator's character and the true King.
But I want it to be with us at all times. So in the last remaining time that we have, I'm going to drop down like I said and try to hit things that I need to hear.
And then I hope that some of you find helpful as well. So going back, we do to point to the answer to our first question, what kind of story are we in right now?
So we do live and we talked about this a little bit in an age of intense conflict, right? Political comes to mind.
There are wars that are like hot wars for the first time, maybe in a lot of regions in my lifetime.
Some of you can remember other times, but because of our access to information, it's very much in our face.
Even though we quickly forget, right? It's a wild thing. There's politics, there's foreign wars. You don't even have to go that deep.
You can just log on to Facebook or Instagram and see all kinds of arguments about what's fake news and which side had this right.
And what happened here and how terrible are they, them over there?
I was talking to a good friend of mine, not that long ago. And he like me has a young son and he said to me, he said, you know, I'm really grateful for the time we live in because I really don't want my son,
I don't want your sons to have to go to war ever. I would hate for them to be conscripted into the service.
And I was like, I don't want that either. But while I appreciate that, I think I kind of was thinking while I was going through this, I was like, well, actually the reality is my sons, my daughter, me, each of us here,
we were born into a time of war. We dress things up and try to feel like we live in peacetime.
But the fact is, we've been born into a conflict that was raging before us, that's continuing on, and the stakes are actually a lot higher than the geopolitical conflicts that we read about in the news, right?
These are souls, this is eternity. This isn't, oh, they gained some ground for a century. This is forever. And these are souls.
See, it's Lewis at one point, I'm going to give him two because I'm a Lewis guy, at one point says, you know, nations fall, kingdoms fall, but the people that you interact with every day, they're made for eternity.
The institutions that we build here will, outside of the church, will fall, right? You can look all across human history, empires fall.
But one name, one kingdom, one institution, family of God, lasts forever. So, you may never pick up a physical weapon. I hope that my children never have to be forced into the military if they make that choice. That's a different story.
We'll pray for that, but regardless of whether you ever pick up a physical weapon, experience physical violence, ever face a firing squad or physical torment, make no mistake, you are under fire.
The moment that you became a believer, if you have made that declaration, you have positioned yourself as an enemy to what is called the Lord of this current age, Satan.
And one writer put it this way, when you became a Christian, you established a new relationship with the powers of darkness. I mean, you got a target.
Now, David Platt actually recently, I just saw a quote from him that I couldn't not throw in. You're in a wrestling match with cosmic powers of darkness. Whether you realize it or not, that's kind of sobering.
Most of us think we live in peacetime, right? I get my quiet time. I go to church on Sunday. I don't cheat on my taxes. I don't cheat on my spouse. I do a decent job at work.
Things are going to work out. But Jesus doesn't actually hide this reality at all. He says, if anyone would come after me, he must deny himself. Take up his cross and follow me.
That's not super exciting for a peacetime. And then in John 1633, in the world you will have tribulation. You may have tribulation. It might be tough some days.
You will have tribulation, but take heart. I have overcome the world.
So, oh man, time is getting tight.
Alright, so we talked earlier about false kings, fabricated kingdoms, disordered fears. So, just quick note on that.
There are many great folks out there creating great content. Christians, some non-Christians that are common grace putting stuff out there that's really helpful.
I don't think that that's something that we have to trash. But I think we have to be careful about how we approach them, how we submit to the rulers of this world, the kings, so to speak, of our age.
I saw the other day and I've heard from a few folks that Joe Rogan is going to church. People were very excited about this.
Because he's someone who is obviously not a believer and he's attending church. And I got a text message that said, we need to pray.
And I said, that's great. We do. We should pray for all the lost. But regardless of what happens with that king, that ruler, that person with influence, and this could go for anyone that you may be value their input from a non-Christian standpoint.
Wouldn't you be careful not to be more invested in that than the words that we get from our true king?
And then the last point I think is examining ourselves. Have we in a world with unimaginable, even a century ago, unimaginable resources and comforts and authority, the things that we can do, have we set ourselves up as false kings?
Do we fabricate kingdoms and do we allow disordered fears to speak and have the loudest voice in the decisions that we make?
Kiss the sun.
I think that this is something that we would all do well to meditate on. The sun is the one who brings justice. He's also the one who brings mercy.
We see in our opening passage of scripture this morning, Isaiah 42, I'm going to read that again.
Maybe today you are hungry for justice. Maybe you see the wrong in the world. Wrong has been committed against you. Maybe wrong against the unborn.
Maybe against children in abusive homes. Maybe people in war zones. Take heart. He's bringing justice.
Maybe today you desperately long for mercy. Maybe you are very aware of your brokenness or the brokenness of someone near you.
Take heart. His mercy is more than enough. A bruised reed, he went out and broke.
Jesus says in Matthew 11, and this is the king. This is the one who will bear the rod of iron. This is him. This is who's talking.
Come to me. All who labor and are heavy laden, and I will give you rest. Take my yoke up on you and learn from me, for I am gentle and lowly in heart.
And you will find rest for your souls. Let's get real practical here at the end.
My brother is here today. I'm grateful to have a little bit of time with him.
The last few years he's gotten really into jiu-jitsu. Some of you may not be familiar, but it's martial art. It's kind of like wrestling. I guess some people might think.
But it's designed specifically for a smaller, weaker individual to be able to defend themselves against a larger, stronger individual.
In fact, it's really counterintuitive. When it was first introduced to the masses it seemed wild, because it actually puts you on your back with your opponent on top of you, which has got to be the most vulnerable position.
Anybody who's ever seen a schoolyard fight knows that is not where you want to be. Flat on your back, on the ground with somebody raining down on you.
My wife broke up one of these just the other day at school. But in fact, jiu-jitsu is designed for this. And they call that position the most vulnerable position, the guard. It's your guard.
Wow. But over time, the decades since that's been introduced to the masses, it's become apparent. This is actually really effective.
So what seemed to be the most vulnerable position has actually become a position of strength. That's not unlike what we're told to do. Put yourself in a vulnerable position. The thing that the world says you could never do and succeed.
Love your enemy. Turn the other cheek. Choose to serve rather than being served. Take up your cross. That's nuts. That's crazy. Lay down flat on your back. Let your opponent get on top of you. You're bigger, stronger opponent.
But that is how this upside-down kingdom, as you may have heard it called, works with this king. Because he is just. He does bear the rod of iron. But he is also merciful. And he will embrace those who embrace him.
In fact, we are told that those who take refuge in him will be blessed. So I know I'm running out of time. So I just want to lay this out as a challenge and a word of hope to each of us.
Men who are here, some of you are husbands, many fathers, grandfathers, I know even, in the room. As you think about your role, put on the armor of God. And remember in Ephesians when he talks about this armor.
And then when Jesus tells Peter that the gates of hell will not prevail, I think I want you to keep in mind that gates are not an offensive weapon. We are meant to engage with the evil one. We don't hunker down and put our walls up.
There's a sword, and it's the word. So men, take heart. Cover your family with prayer. As we go through the Psalms of the summer, engage with that. Lament where we lament. Praise where we can praise. Know that he can handle both.
Women, some of you are wives, some mothers, many friends, different stages of life. But the Proverbs 31 woman gets thrown around a lot. And I've seen that burden crush women the way that it's presented.
So when you hear the verse 25 in Proverbs 31, strength and dignity are her clothing, and she laughs at the time to come. Christ is that strength and dignity. And you can laugh because you know that he holds it and he's coming back.
And so our last question, how does it end? Well, kiss the sun. Lest he be angry and you perish in the way, for his wrath is quickly kindled. But blessed are all who take refuge in him. Christ our King, he's come. He's risen.
He's defeated our enemy, but the battle rages until he returns. So let's seek hope in him. And as we come to the table this morning, Brandon's going to mention that. I just hope that you're blessed by the truth of a just and merciful King, Jesus. Let's pray.
Father, we thank you. Thank you for our King. I pray that the words that you've poured out through your scriptures would sink deep into our hearts and changes, that they would not just be good ideas, but that they would be truth that transforms and upholds us in our weakness and our brokenness.
I pray blessing on each who are here, blessing on your church around the globe, Lord, as we seek to wage this paradoxical war against the evil one and the brokenness in our own hearts. Thank you for your spirit that does the work for us and intercedes for us even now, Lord.
Pray this in the name of our King. Amen.